[موسيقى
] أردت أن أحاول إنشاء شيء
لم تره من قبل ،
شيء سحري
روحي ، شيء روحي
يمكن أن يساعد في إعادة ربط البشرية
وما هي أفضل طريقة للقيام بذلك من
خلال مواقع التراث العالمي لليونسكو
اليوم لدينا 30 من  لوحات موقع التراث العالمي
على متاهة الأدغال ، وسأكمل بحلول
نهاية العام 50 في الوقت المناسب للاحتفال
باريس أم
بالذكرى السنوية الخمسين
[موسيقى]
عندما تصعد على مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر ، إنها
متاهة وهي تلك المواقع الثلاثين بالإضافة إلى
العرب البرجوازية في نهاية المتاهة ،
لماذا فعلنا الطريق المنحدر البرجوازي ، أعتقد
أنها كانت مجرد فرصة
لمعرفة أنك تعرف أن البرج
هو مبنى مبدع في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، يتعرف الناس عليه حقًا
،
فإن الخطوط المعمارية له مذهلة جدًا
و  لقد كانت مجرد فرصة
تعرفها لتظهرها على مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر ،
لم يكن هناك أبدًا معرض فني
أو أي عمل فني على مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر في الأدغال
وأنا سعيد جدًا لأن النتيجة جميلة جدًا
أمها  إنه عالم آخر قليلاً
وعندما تكون على مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر في الأدغال في
اليوم تتجول في المتاهة
ولأن المتاهات ترى من خلال الجدران ، فأنت
تعلم أنك ترى دبي بأكملها إنه أمر
مدهش ومع ذلك فأنت من بين 30
موقعًا للتراث العالمي  وكل هذا الجمال
وكل هذا التاريخ ،
فإن المواقع كما قلت في جميع
القارات الست في العالم ، فإن المواقع
الأقرب إلينا هي في مصر
مع الأهرامات من الواضح أن
الهند التي هي قريبة جدًا من
تاج محل ، يتم تمثيل تاج محل  تاج
محل هو واحد من الأشياء المفضلة لدي
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لديك واحد فقط
مثير للاهتمام في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
لديك
اليابان
الصين ولديك مسقط رأس بوذا وهو
أمر روحي ومذهل للغاية ،
إنه أمر صعب إذا كانت هذه
مبدعة جدًا  ويمكن التعرف عليه ، إنه
كيف
تجعلهم يشعرون بالسحر مرة أخرى كما
تعلم وهذا هو كل ما يدور في عملي
حول جعل
السحر العادي والمألوف مرة أخرى
[موسيقى] ،
لذا آمل أن تساعد هذه المواقع في
تسليط الضوء على  قلبنا على ماضينا
تاريخنا ولكن أيضًا إعادة ربطنا
بروح الأرض ثم المساعدة في زيادة
الوعي والمال من خلال المشروع
لتغذية العودة إلى مساعدة اليونسكو في
الحفاظ على
ثقافتنا
أنت